Slatkin: Well, hello.
Welcome to my talk.
It's called
"Large-scale Data Analysis
Using the App Engine
Pipeline API."
My name is Brett Slatkin.
I'm a software engineer
on the Google App Engine team.
These are the
hashtags for this,
and our feedback form,
that's a 1.
So "1gGbS."
Couldn't possibly
be any harder.
Sure I'll get some
great feedback. Anyway.
Here are the two projects we're
kind of talking about today,
"appengine-pipeline"
and "mapreduce,"
the MapReduce projects.
I also realize
that it's kind of bad
to put a 301 session
as the last session
of an entire conference,
which is what this is,
so there's a lot of code
in this presentation,
and I realize it might be very
hard for you to read,
so luckily,
you all have tablets
and other things
to read things on,
so this is linked to the slides
that you're about to see.
So if you want to
follow along and can't read,
it's,
"goo.gl/P2U2S."
So you can click on that,
or download that
and check it out.
It's PDF.
Okay, so let's talk
about, kind of,
motivation for
the Pipeline API,
and then I'll kind of talk
about what it is and--
and all that.
So--so there's
something, you know,
people want to do
that's very common,
it's the data join.
What is
a data join?
Basically, we're saying,
I have a bunch of data
and I want to do a join on it,
like an SQL join.
I want to join two
unrelated tables together
into a single view.
I want to combine data
by the features that it has.
And you want to do this
for all kinds of reasons,
the same reasons you
want to do an SQL join,
because you want to join--
generate views or reports
or any kind of aggregate
data or derivative data.
So some examples of this
is any kind of ranking,
doing heat-map diagrams,
any kind of fiscal roll-ups,
stats, et cetera.
And, you know, so since
you know what you want to do,
why you want to do it,
when do you want to do it?
I mean, you need to do
a join when the data sources
are kind of mismatched for what
you're trying to accomplish.
So each data set that you're
trying to analyze or join
has something else
that it's optimized for.
So logging is optimized
for rate li--write latency,
and then, especially with
a high replication Datastore,
a lot of things
are optimized
for per-user views,
not global views.
So you want to
join different data
that's optimized for
totally different uses
to produce other outputs
for a third use, you know.
So that's kind of what
we're talking about.
When you'd really
want to do a data join.
Now, what makes this all unique
from just a standard SQL join
is that you have
a lot of data,
so you can't just do it in
an SQL table with a simple join
or and in-memory join.
There's just too much
information.
So that's why
I'm calling it "data join."
So I wanted to use, like,
a real example for this.
So I wanted to just
give one that really,
I think,
everyone can relate to.
I was going to do
a contrived example,
but I think this one's
a little more solid.
So it's
a sales report. Okay?
We've got simple Datastore
kinds, tables, we've got sales,
so what was sold
to a customer
that's basically
customers to items.
So "many-to-many" table.
Pretty easy.
We have the items.
How much they cost.
Item-to-cost,
it's one-to-one.
And then we have
categories of things.
So what kind of thing
is an item?
So items have
many categories.
And, so here's some
example data
in our fake business
tables here.
We have "A"--
customers "A," "B," and "C."
We've got "milkshakes,"
"pies," and "fries."
We've got categories
that these can belong to:
"desserts,"
"food," or "drinks."
Then we have a price
for each one.
So a milkshake is both
a dessert and a drink.
It's not rocket science.
But, something you might
want to do with this information
is generate a report.
Right?
So you've got custo--
you want to know how much
is each customer spending
and what category is
making you the most revenue.
Very simple,
like, desirable thing,
and most of you would say,
"Well, this is really easy.
I'll just do a join
of an SQL table."
And you may know
that--
Well, I'll get to that
in a second.
So here's the SQL
that would do this.
So you have--if you
want to do by customer,
you just do a join of the
sales table to the items table,
and that would--and group
by the customer I.D.
If you want to do it
by category,
you kind of have to do
a triple join.
I'm sure that someone
in the room knows
how to do this with
no joins in SQL.
I'm just trying
to emphasize
that you need multiple joins,
usually,
to do this kind of thing.
So you join "categories" to
"sales" and "sales" to "items"
and then you sum up
by the item price.
The problem is that
this eventually will break.
At some point, you will get
so much data in your Datastore
that you cannot do
these joins anymore.
And so
I think that it's--
so what we're talking about
and what--
the way I'm trying to frame this
is that you want
this information,
these aggregates,
these roll-ups,
and you want them
to keep working forever
no matter how
much data you have.
So that's
a big problem,
and the solution
that people usually say is,
"Oh, MapReduce.
I will just use MapReduce
and that will solve everything."
It's like,
"Throw some MapReduce on it.
It's great."
And that's true.
It keeps working
at extreme sizes.
Oh, so, ooh, that was
a big diagram, huh?
Okay, so MapReduce
is great.
The problem is that MapReduce
doesn't actually solve this.
There's a whole bunch of
different kinds of data analysis
that you cannot do
in a single MapReduce.
So what you find is that people
end up making MapReduces
that are multiple stages
or very deep.
So they run
one MapReduce,
take the output of that
into another MapReduce,
and so on and so forth.
Excuse me.
So let me give you
an example.
Here's a diagram of
when you might do this.
So here's the same joins
again,
the roll-ups that I just
told you about,
as a series of MapReduces.
So I'm going to
step you through this,
so don't worry.
So in blue are Maps.
On the left we have
Mapping categories,
Mapping items,
Mapping sales.
So we Map "itemIds"
to "Categories,"
"itemIds" to "Prices,"
"itemIds" to "Customers."
Then we do a Shuffle and Reduce
to join them on the "itemId"
that basically collates
them all by the "itemId"
and aggregates them
together.
So then we have a Mapping
of "itemIds" to the categories,
the costs,
and a list of customer sales.
Then we run a Map
on the output of that
and then invert that--
those key value pairs.
So then we output a list
of "categories to cost"
and of "customerIds
to cost,"
and then we Shuffle and Reduce
that to collate or join
on "Category"
and "Customer" again.
And at the end,
it spits out
the sum of all costs per--
for each category or
for each "customerId." Okay?
There are more efficient
ways to do this,
but I'm just trying to
illustrate the example here.
I think that this is a common
use case that you'll see.
So it's great.
You can solve this
with MapReduces.
Isn't that awesome?
Wonderful. Well,
there's a few things
that are actually kind of
difficult about this.
It's mostly a solution,
but now you have a new problem,
which is how do you actually run
all these MapReduces?
If I asked you what to do
with a lot of big data,
you'd say,
"Oh, I'll use a dup,
I'll use a MapReduce."
But if I said,
"You have five MapReduces.
Connect them together," name
a tool off the top of your head.
Maybe people
will say "Oozie,"
which is the thing
from Yahoo for hadoop,
but it's not like there's
a common thing we all agree on
for the go--
to tool for this
in the open source toolkit.
So that's kind of the problem.
And the reason is
that Fan-in is really hard.
It's hard to
make this work.
And Fan-in is this thing
on the left,
mapping "Categories,"
mapping "Items,"
mapping "Sales,"
all separately and then
Shuffling them together
or joining them together.
So that's Fanning-in.
That's what we're
trying to do.
And it turns out
that Fan-in
is actually
just a type of workflow.
So you're saying, you know,
"Do this, then that,"
or, "Wait," you know,
"Do this thing,
then wait for these three
other things to finish."
It's kind of
a general problem,
and so if you've solve
the general problem--I know
"workflow" is a dirty word,
but if you've, kind of,
solved the workflow problem,
then in a similar way it should
solve the Fan-in problem too.
Okay. So hopefully
that makes sense.
Are people with me so far?
So great. Okay.
So I just want to talk about
some workflow Prior Art
really quickly.
Workflow is like content
management systems.
It is the--
it's a dirty word.
It's, like, a terrible thing.
Like, don't ever say,
"I have created the world's
foremost workflow engine,"
or, "content management system."
Like, it's,
you know, terrible.
Sorry, but-- And so I wanted
to kind of just throw some mud
or basically show you
how I've been unhappy
with the workflow tools
out there.
I'm not trying to create
a generalized workflow platform.
Don't worry.
This is about data
and I'll get back to why.
But, I wanted to just
kind of frame the context here
a little bit.
So the first one
is finite state machines.
So I have had a
lot of experience building
finite state machines
at Google.
I built a cluster
management tool
that I'll show you in a sec.
The App Engine billing system is
mostly a finite state machine.
There's a lot of
high-performance flows
throughout Google
that are state machines.
The problem is it's just
this explosion of states.
You've got determinates
of behavior,
you've got a small number
of states in the beginning,
and then what happens
is every time
you need to add a feature
you add more states,
and you get this
kind of, like,
combinatorial
explosion of behavior.
It's really hard to work with
somebody else on something
that has a, kind of,
finite state machine semantics.
It's hard to have an interface.
It's hard to do reuse.
It's very difficult
to test.
There's tons of examples
out there.
There's Fantasm
for App Engine,
which we have an article about.
You should read about.
I'm not trying to knock Fantasm
in particular.
For certain thing--
for certain workloads
finite state machines
are very good,
but for the kind of thing
I wanted to do,
I don't think
it's a good fit.
Oozie is
the other one
that is kind of like
a finite state machine.
You describe, I swear,
you describe
your whole state machine
in XML with, like,
"if" statements in XML
and stuff like that,
and it's really verbose.
This is the state diagram
for my project
that did cluster management.
This is not my state diagram,
this is the one I replaced.
It's, like, 70 states,
this deleted all of the error
states and error transitions,
and they're like,
"Hey, maintain this."
And it's--no.
I'm not going to do that.
Like, I'm going to replace it
with something else. Right?
So, okay, yeah.
so--alright, keep going.
So another one's
work queues.
This is very similar to
App Engine queues or Gearman,
if you've heard of that.
Producer style--
consumer style queues,
everything's
a small chunk of, kind of,
equal size or large,
you know, but equal size.
The input and output's
really well defined.
The big thing here is
that they're linear, you know,
Do "A" then "B" then "C"
then "D" then "E," always.
Or dump it
in the error bucket.
And I think that work queues
work really well
for that kind of stuff.
I feel like
you see that a lot.
But there's really
no control flow.
If you need to branch off to
a whole different set of logic,
that's very difficult to do,
and so it's hard to test the
whole workflow from end to end
if you need to try
variations of, you know,
kind of, how to progress
through the workflow.
Another kind is
Data dependencies.
We have a bunch of
these at Google.
Think about, like, "make,"
the semantics of a "make" file,
but instead of being
"cc" files and ".o" files,
it's input data
and output data,
and instead of running
a compiler,
you're running MapReduce
for eight hours.
It's really cool.
It's really, really cool.
The coolest thing it can do
is incremental builds.
That's really cool.
So you can say, okay, build
this hard thing once a day,
build these small things
a hundred times a day,
and then
with the final result,
go spit out
some other output data.
So that's--
that's really cool.
It's great for that.
Zero control flow.
It's, like,
totally declarative.
You can't have any outside input
or intervention from a human.
It has to be all files.
You can only really
test it as black-box,
so inputs and outputs.
Just look at the data.
We haven't open-sourced
any of these
because they're so tightly
coupled to their infrastructures
so I don't expect to see
any of those out there.
And the last one
is flow oriented,
so this is Cascading.
If you've ever used Cascading,
that's flow oriented.
So you convert your data
into this tuple/tuple space,
you define transforms
on the arbitrary tuples.
It's awesome because
it automatically optimizes
your code by figuring out
the graph of what you're doing
in transforms and then, you
know, it'll merge, you know,
certain operations and
do all kinds of cool stuff.
I think that this
is really cool,
but it's really complex,
and you have to buy
into the religion
that is flow processing.
And for most people,
you--you know,
this isn't even useful until you
get over a Terabyte of data,
so you don't even need to do it.
Right?
And there's no glue,
so you can't--
at some point, you might just
need to shell out and, you know,
download a file or, you know,
ca--you know, "cat"
something or look at a list
somewhere, like, hit a--
ping a server,
like, whatever.
You need some kind of glue in
order to do certain workflows.
I think
that's really important.
So I think
this is cool, cool stuff,
but I don't think
it's quite right
for what I want it to do.
Okay, so "How the Pipeline API
is different."
So basically it took all,
kind of, these different systems
that are already there
and tried to learn from them,
and the other thing
that kind of carried--
I carried--you know,
kind of carried into this
was thinking about
functional languages
like Erlang and--
and Haskell.
And so one of
the coolest things
about those besides the fact
that, you know,
you have to use your brain
differently in order
to use them is that
they are parallelizable.
So when someone says,
"I like functional programming,"
and you ask them why,
and it's like,
"I like the style,"
it's like yes, that's--
the style is cool.
But the coolest reason
is that you can just,
you know, when you do a
fold or something like that,
it can run on
multiple machines.
That's why it's cool;
it's parallelizable.
That's the point.
It's a first-class
part of the language,
is the fact that it can
be optimized in ways
you don't even understand,
and that's really cool.
So I wanted to see, can
I carry over some of those ideas
to languages
I like to use?
I don't think I'm smart enough
to use Haskell.
I've tried;
cannot do it.
I don't know,
maybe there'd be,
like a Haskell for Python
programmers kind of tutorial
I could read.
That would be nice,
but it's too hard.
And so I wanted to
carry those over to--
to Python and Java
and see, you know,
what it could be like.
Oh.
I wanted to have--I wanted to
link back to the slides here.
Just in case because with--
now it's, like, a lot of code.
So "P2U2S" if you
want the slides.
P2U2S.
So okay.
So here are
my assumptions.
I have a lot--
I have a lot of threads.
I've got extremely
highly available storage,
which is awesome.
I've got elastic scaling--
scaling of dynamic instances,
so the queues
will just spool them up.
I've got apps for
thousands of instances,
and I don't have to configure
any-- configure anything.
I just--it just--
they just get spooled up,
which is pretty crazy
assumptions.
And then my goals
were kind of different
than a lot of
other kind of workflow
or data oriented engines.
I didn't want to be
deterministic specifically.
Functional testing
was a core part of what
I wanted to be able to do.
I wanted the components that you
generate to be fully reusable
so that people
can actual--
multiple teams can
actually build tools,
like workflows that build
on the same data.
I want it to be productionized,
so that's like having tools
to look at the state of
the process as it's running,
or to diagnose problems
when things fail,
to have "back off"
and "retry, "
and then I want it
to be minimal,
so what's the minimal
number of tools
I need in order
to build this.
Non goals: static analysis.
I'm not doing that.
Automatic optimization
I don't want to do.
I'm not trying to make
a flow system.
I'm not trying to create
sustainable flow rates,
and I don't want to use XML.
I don't want BPEL in there.
Yeah.
Okay, so the types of work
I do want to do,
so first of all is
synchronous work.
So up until yesterday, up to 10
minutes was a task queue task.
That was the limit.
Now you can go
as long as you want
as long as you have an
instant surround of a backend.
So synchronous work
is what web service calls
doing a lot of transactions,
any kind of iteration
on the Datastore
that takes a really long time.
If you just want to write your
code in a straight line, do it.
That's the first--
that's the easiest and fastest
and first way to do anything,
so just do it.
That's a great place to start.
I want to be able to support
that work and let that code,
like, run for a long time
if you want to--
You know, you don't have to keep
maintaining it or something.
Then I also want to allow for
asynchronous work.
So fire off the work,
wait for a callback,
and then tie-in with other
frameworks to you know,
basically tell them to start
and then have them call you back
when they're done
and then hook into the rest
of the system like that.
So MapReduce is
a good example of this.
You know,
it takes hours to run.
If you want to send
an email to users,
this is a really simple one.
Like, we have
exceptional things
happen in production
all the time.
If the process
had just told us,
we would've been able
to tell it, like,
"Here's what you should do.
Do the right thing."
But we don't even really have
the tools to do that right now.
So what I'd really like is
if I could run a MapReduce
and it's like, hey, I just hit
a piece of data
that's totally weird,
or something corrupted,
or I don't know
what to do here.
If it could just email me
with a "yes or no"
and a description
of what it saw,
and I could just click "yes"
and then it would go back
to work, that'd be awesome.
Or I could go
and look at the panel
and say, "Oh, yes. Okay.
There's something wrong here.
I'm going to diagnose
the problem right now,"
it--while it's paused,
you know.
So that's like,
that kind of asynchronous work
is really important too.
And then Webhooks, so
post-commit hooks on G.I.D
or anything like that,
I'd want to be able
to interface with.
But, in the end it's all
about the coordination stuff,
so it's--
I'm trying to build glue.
I want to be able
to pass arguments
between different functions
and--and--and pieces of work,
and take their outputs and pass
them to other pieces of work.
I want to be able to spawn
a lot of different child tasks
and wait for them,
and in the end I want
to make "joining" really easy
so that first
diagram I had with the Maps
on the left side,
I want to make that process
of combining data together
really easy.
Okay, so let's talk about
making Python and Java parallel.
Maybe I--
Ah, here's the slides.
Yes. Okay.
That's where it is.
So that's where they are.
Okay, so let's
get into this.
So I'm trying
to define a--I--
trying to define
a subset of Python
and a subset of Java
that can be parallelized
but isn't wacky.
So here's how it started.
Alright.
So here's some Python.
I have
three pipelines here.
The first one is "Add," adds
"a" and "b," returns a value.
"Multiply" multiplies "a"
and "b," returns a value.
But then,
this linear function here
is actually a
multi-stage pipeline with--
that can be--well, this one
can't be parallelized,
but you'll see
what's happening.
So you may remember
a linear function is "y=mx+b."
So here I'm saying "yield"--
I'm using Python
"yield" statement--
"yield"
and you multiply child pipeline.
Give it the parameters
"x" and "slope."
Take "mx,"
which is the future--
it's a FutureValue--
take that future
and then pass it to "add,"
and then also add "offset,"
to there..
Yield that job also,
and then, basically,
return the result.
So this is really
simple syntax,
but what happens is that
"multiply" and "add"
can actually be scheduled
to run in the future.
They don't have to be run
synchronously.
That's like, so it looks
like really simple code.
It is.
That's the point, right?
It almost looks
kind of stupid,
but this--this style of just
allowing you to pass futures
around lets you do
some really powerful things,
which is really cool.
The other thing
I wanted to do
is make it
really easy to invoke.
So now that I have
a linear function,
I want to just pass
in some parameters,
call start, and then
it'll give me back a handle
to talk to this job later,
and then later on
I can just say,
"Hey, from this ID, give me
back that object from before."
Check to see if it's done.
If it is, then I can get--
I can hit the value
and get the result.
So I want to make it
really, really easy
to start and receive
the output of these things.
And then testing.
I wanted testing to be
a first-class thing.
So there's two parts to this.
The first part
is on the bottom here.
So start test.
Because of the way
we're defining pipelines,
you can run them in serial.
So you can use
your Python debugger
and just step through it.
So if you have a problem,
you can run in the whole
pipeline in test mode,
does all the things
you think it should be doing,
and then as soon as you get
an exception stack trace,
the call stack at that point
will be how
you actually got there
through all of
the sub-pipelines.
I've never seen a workflow
tool that can do that.
That's really important to me
because that's the kind of stuff
I need to debug
and then build new tests for.
And then at the end, you
can just grab the values here
and assert--make some assertions
about how the--
how the pipeline ran.
Further, though, sometimes
pipelines take too long
or they have to hit external
resources that aren't there.
So you want to have built--
in mocking facilities for that,
which is what "run test" is.
So "run test"
is a special method
that's also there
that basically says,
"Oh, when you run me
in testing mode,
just do this behavior.
It's good enough
of an approximation
of the real thing for--
for our purposes of testing."
Right?
So for instance,
in MapReduce,
the Mapper Framework,
when it has "run test"
it doesn't have to add tasks,
it doesn't have to do
any scheduling or quotas,
it just takes the data,
calls the map function
on it synchronously,
and then
returns the result.
So you don't have
to do all the work
that you normally would do to--
to--to test the thing.
You can make a fake.
Okay. Yeah.
Alright. So this is
the same thing for Java.
So I'm trying to be,
you know,
equal with my,
kind of, focus here.
The font size
has to be small.
What can I say?
It is a little bit more verbose.
I'm sorry, guys.
But--Yeah, bulk it up.
Yeah.
But, the--
[laughs]
but, I will say for Java
this is pretty pithy,
so it's the same thing.
"Add" and "multiply."
They return two immediate
values, "a + b," "a x b,"
and then we've got
that linear function which is--
computes "mx"
and then passes "mx"
to the "futureCall"
adding "mx + b."
That's it.
And the invocation
style's similar.
You grab the service
from the factory,
you start a new pipeline
with the simple parameters.
Sometime later,
you take that "pipeline id",
grab the certain job info,
look at the output,
look at the sta--status,
see that it's done,
look at the output.
Really simple, right?
Java does not have a functional
testing piece yet,
but that's something
we're working on.
It'll come soon.
It'll work the same way
where you can step
through the Java debugger
to find where your code's
not working the way it should.
Okay, so just to kind of clarify
what we're doing here,
I want to talk about kind of
more of the specifics
about how this thing works.
So FutureValues.
What is a future?
If you've ever done
asynchronous programmer,
used Twisted Python
or anything like that,
it's--FutureValues
are kind of a weird thing
to get your head around
and I think
Twisted Python programmers,
they are constructed
differently often.
As programmers,
they just,
they think about things
very differently,
much like functional
programmers think
about things differently.
But, I wanted the
Pipeline API to be really easy
to understand and make it look
like procedural code,
but there are still
restrictions.
So FutureValues,
when you call "yield Multiply"
and get back a result,
you can't access it right now.
You can't do that.
It'll raise an exception
that'll say,
"You can't do this."
You can't grab the value,
and there's no way
to actually wait for it.
So the function's
not even there.
It's not even defined.
But what you can do is
you can create another child
that reads the result.
So you can create a LogValue
that will log a value
that's passed through it,
and then you can pass
a future to that pipeline.
So a really simple idea.
This--this one works.
So essentially anything that's
passed into your "run" method,
you can access.
That's the gist of this.
And this is what lets you
do all these cool things.
So again,
immediate values,
if you're past it
in your "run" method,
then you can do anything
you want with it.
You can do comparisons,
you can pass it to functions,
whatever you want.
It's just a value.
But, the key thing
here is that when you
pass values
between different pipelines--
so here I'm passing the output
of "Multiply" to "LogValue"--
"Multiply" is going
to run in one task,
totally on its own,
up to ten minute deadline,
and "LogValue" is going
to run in its own task,
totally separate,
for ten minutes.
They're totally separated
from each other
and the Pipeline API is
coordinating the communication
of the results between them.
Okay? It looks like procedural
code, but it's not.
Java works the same way.
You cannot access
the value of a future.
It just doesn't work.
So when you make
a "futureCall, "
you can't call
a "getValue."
There's no such method.
But you can take that
value of the future
and pass it to another
job, like "PrintIt,"
which will then
print the value.
So it works exactly
the same way.
So just really simple semantics
for how to deal with futures.
Java med--immediates
work exactly the same way.
The only difference
is that you have to wrap them
in this immediate
little function wrapper
or method wrapper.
We'll--we'll probably make
that shorter to like,
"I," or something,
or "M" or--I--I don't know.
Sometime.
But that's all it takes.
So let's talk about
why this works.
This is--so this is--
hopefully we'll now
clarify everything
we've just been talking about.
So here's a pipeline.
I'm sorry if I'm giving you
math flashbacks.
Here's a polynomial function.
You might remember
"A x 2 + B x + C" gives you
some kind of polynomial,
some variety.
So I have "Add" which
takes multiple values
and sums them,
I have "Multiply"
which will multiply multiple
values together.
So this is kind of
the same things from before.
And now I have
three child pipelines here.
So "Ax = yield
Multiply (A, x, x),"
then I have
"Bx = yield Multiply (B, x)."
Now, what's really cool is
I can run those in parallel.
And the Pipeline API
will do that.
So when you yield those
two things and it's like,
"Oh, I have no data
dependencies,"
it just runs them.
And they run
in two separate tasks--
two separate tasks, with as much
of a deadline as they can have,
and then when they're done,
they pass the results back
and then the "Add" child
gets kicked off,
which took it's--
those results
and then it runs.
So that's what I'm talking
about coordination in Fan-in.
So let's go
through, like,
a graphical version
of this, 'cause it--
hopefully this'll
solidify
what I'm talking about.
So on the left are
immediate values,
"A," "B," "X," and "C."
Okay?
The green boxes are tasks.
The blue Slots are data
that we're going to generate,
and then we'll talk
about the Barrier.
So straightaway, once
you say "Pipeline start,"
it's like, "Well, okay.
I've immediate values
on "Multiply."
These guys are good to go."
It schedules tasks.
The tasks run,
and when the tasks are done,
they fill the Slots.
The tasks can run in any order.
It doesn't matter.
They can be item potent.
They might run multiple times.
It doesn't matter. The--those
are the semantics of the API.
And when each Slot is filled,
it'll notify the Barrier.
The Barrier will wait
for both Slot A and B,
in any order, to be done.
Once they're both done,
it'll notify "Add"
and will say, "Run."
"Add" will then go find
the parameters it needs,
pull them in Slot
"A," "B," and "C,"
do what it needs to do,
and then fill Slot "C"
and then it'll call you back
and basically say, "I'm done."
And now you can go grab
the result of the polynomial.
That's it.
Make sense so far?
People getting it?
Okay, cool.
Okay, so demo--I have
like a small demo of this.
Okay, so I have this--this
is my Favorite Color Guestbook.
This is some--
a lot of data here.
I know you came to see
large-scale data analysis,
so I didn't--
did not fail to deliver here.
So I've got, like,
at least 500 colors in here
that people like,
I'm pretty sure.
Anyway, so what you
can do is you can add a color,
so you know, orange or--
oh, there we go--
wireless is working, okay--
azure is a great color.
I like that one.
It's a really nice color.
Okay, so I'll run
a reporting pipeline and--
and so this says,
"Send me an email of
the count of favorite colors."
Okay?
So let's just do the basic--
the basic kind.
Three colors we like.
Blue. Alright.
So you click "Run" and now
this is going to redirect us
to this UI.
I'm going to
turn off autopilot
just so we don't
overwhelm ourselves.
Okay, so what happens is,
the--the pipeline's now running
and this is the production
interface and you--
if you went to Mike Aizatskyi's
talk on MapReduce,
it's the same UI.
The UI is generated
from the callGraph.
You don't have
to do anything.
You just get the UI.
It'--just--that's--
we just figure it out
from how your code works.
That's the point.
And the same UI is used
in Java and Python
because it's all JavaScript.
We just take the description
of your graph and we render it.
That's all there is to it.
And then it's got a bunch
of facilities in it, so--
you--the--the pipeline
is going along here.
I'll describe what it's doing.
You can watch it as it goes.
You can see that the--
the current leftmost,
newest pipeline is
selected automatically.
That's part of what it does.
And, so it'll progress and--
and we'll get into it.
So the key--
the key things here, though,
are that you--you--
you see every sub-stage
that was created,
you see how the parameters
were passed between them,
you see
what the outputs were,
you see who filled
the outputs.
If I go down here to a task--
You don't really have to know
what these are,
but the point is--
Let me make this bigger.
I'm sorry.
So here's
an "Append" operation.
"Append" is doing a Fan-out--
a Fan-in.
It's taking
three different jobs
and adding them all
into one list. Okay?
And so here you can see
the first value is filled
by this "LongCount" operation,
the second value is filled
by this other one,
and the th--and the third one
is filled by this other one,
and then "Append"
just mashed them all together
and then
it outputted something--
output something here.
So you--you can inspect
your own call graph as it ran,
then you'd be, like,
"Hey, why did this break?
What happened?
Why am I in "retry"
or "backoff"?"
And by--by default,
Pipeline API will actually email
you when something breaks.
So you, like,
you have to turn that off.
And you can click around,
so you can be, like,
"Oh, "LongCount,"
what did that do?"
And you can click on it
and it goes there and so on.
So I'm going to
run this again, if I can.
Da, da, da--
Let's see.
How many times
do I need to push "back"?
This is a bug.
It's the "back" button.
What can I say?
Oh, you know what's good
is just deleting
the URL bar.
Okay. So
try this again.
I want to just highlight
another part of this
which is the--the--kind of--
the production piece which is,
when I run the pipeline--
there's a pipeline here.
You'll see
it turns yellow.
That's one that's
in the "retry" state.
I have one here
that just automatically
just raises an exception,
just to show
what it looks like.
So you'll see it
on the left here.
It's a useless pipeline,
and it's, like, it just--
it just "errored,"
and it's going to--it's like,
here's the exception string.
So "Whoops, I need to retry,"
is what it said,
and it's retrying
and it says
it'll run in 14 seconds.
And if you click here,
it says, well,
it's going to run in one second,
and then the second time around
it runs, and then it's done.
And this is just all on the task
queue in the background.
Now, what this thing
actually does,
I can describe
really quickly.
What happens is, there's
a function that gets called
called "SplitCount."
"SplitCount" says,
"I have these guestbook posts.
They have an attribute
called "color."
I want to know the counts
for red and blue."
So it'll go and it'll spit out
two child pipelines
that do LongCounts,
that just basically do a query
and just keep going, iterating,
until it gets to the end.
And so they'll count
up to 10,000
or it's for ten minutes,
or as long as you want.
With cursors,
you can just keep going,
so you can count
as many objects as you want
and do that--do that
report generation.
And then finally,
when LongCount's done,
it's like,
"I have the answer."
It says it's done,
the output gets set out,
and then it goes
and tells all of its--
all of its
dependent pipelines.
So here's "Append."
"Append" waits for those
two, like I said before,
and then at the very end,
basically,
there's an aggregation
of all those reports
across all the different tasks
down into this email
and the email basically says,
"Hey, here's--
here's Brett's email address.
Send him an email
with this report.
We found 97 red
and 130 blue" Okay?
So it--it--
it--what--what--
what this actually does
is totally stupid.
The point is
that you have the tools
to look at all of
the different parameters,
how they're passed,
how much time they took,
why they--why they went
into an error state,
et cetera, et cetera.
So it's a really
nice debugging tool.
You can also can--add consoles
and links to every single job
in a status message.
So you can have a graph here
of how things are going.
And, I think I have
a word count demo.
So here's, like,
a more advanced--
Let's see if that loads.
If that loads,
that'd be cool.
Really?
Oh, there it is. Okay.
So here's,
like, another--
this is like a hacked-up
word count pipeline I had
from some other time.
But what's cool here
is you can see, like,
here's a shuffler--
Oh, wait.
That's not a good example.
Da da da da.
So here's, like,
the Mapper Framework
running inside the Pipeline API.
Okay?
So the point is
that, you know,
you can do all kinds of
really cool stuff here
just creating
consoles for yourself,
and it just kind of
builds the UI for you.
You don't have to,
like, worry about that.
Oh, and it reloads
and automatically--
that's the autopilot feature--
it reloads
and automatically finds
the next cool thing to look at.
So it's pretty nice.
That's--
that just comes for free.
Okay, so let's talk
about a few more, kind of,
details of what
the Pipeline API can do,
and then we'll get back to
our motivating example.
So Fan-out.
Again, this is really simple.
I want to send
a bunch of emails to people.
Sometimes emails happen to
take a long time to send,
or, you know,
you have to retry.
So here I have
an "EmailInvites" pipeline.
It takes an "event id," it goes
to the Datastore, gets it.
It goes through all the people
who are invited
and then it sends
an email to them.
It yields a child
for each one.
For each "to" address,
send them an email.
Alright?
Pretty simple.
The cool thing is
that this code,
"EmailInvites"
will run linearly.
It'll just run through.
Every time you yield a child,
that will
get scheduled for running
in the future,
and then as soon
as this finishes,
all the children
will start running.
It'll just kick off.
Fan-in is also
similarly interesting.
So I had this great idea
for a search engine.
I want to take the--the word
count of every link on the page,
like, what it links to,
and that's how you determine
the quality of the current page.
So if you've got more links
to content that's bigger,
it's better.
That's my, like,
million dollar idea here.
So I--I built the beginnings
of this search engine.
I have a new pipeline
called "WordCountURL."
It goes and fetches a URL
and it splits the data
and counts how many words
are on it,
and then returns
that value.
So that's the top.
That's synchronous.
That could take
ten minutes,
or maybe it'll take
30 minutes,
maybe you want to do some more
interesting processing on it.
The--it doesn't
really matter.
I've got a "sum" pipeline that
just adds up a bunch of values,
and then I have
my search engine pipeline.
It says,
"Hey, here's a bunch of URLs
I found in this page.
Please go fetch all of them,
count up how many words
are on each one,
sum them together,
and then return the result."
So you do a "for" loop
through the URLs,
you yield the child pipeline
for all of them,
and then you sum the results
of all the children.
So this is a barrier
on all of the child pipelines.
All of the different
"WordCountURL" child pipelines,
they'll all go out and run
and then once all of them
have completed,
all of the answers
will be aggregated together
and then handed to "Sum."
"Sum" will add them up
and then say,
"Here's the total,"
and then "MyPipeline"
will complete the total.
So that's Fan-in.
I mean,
it's really simple.
This shouldn't look like much
because it's not,
but you can do
really powerful things
just with
that simple mechanism.
Sequencing
is another thing
you need to do.
So you want to say,
"Run "JobA" then run "JobB,"
and once they're both--
you know,
after both of those,
go clean up some files
I accidentally wrote
along the way.
And then after that,
you know,
update the dashboard
and email the team."
Sometimes you just
want to do stuff in order
if you don't have
any data dependencies,
so you have a way
of describing that.
Okay, that same stuff in Java.
Fan-out.
"SendEmail"
is the same thing.
We don't really
have to look at it.
"SendInvites,"
same thing again.
I pass in the serializeable
invite object
that's got
some properties.
It goes through,
spawns a child for each one.
That's all there is to it.
This fans out,
they all run immediately.
It's great.
And then, same thing
with Fan-in.
So with Fan-in,
I've got--
here I've got the "WordCountURL"
and "Sum" again.
In Java I've got to get
a few more things.
I've got to get some
"UTF-8" in there,
got to get some kind of,
like, factories,
but, you know, not so bad.
I had to go on the next page.
What can I say?
But, here again you see
I have a list of results.
I call "WordCountURL"
for each URL that I received,
and then I take the list
and I pass it to "Sum"
and I return that at the bottom.
So Fan-in is also very easy
to describe in Java.
This making sense
so far to people?
Also? Okay.
Cool.
And sequencing on Java
is exactly the same.
You have another parameter,
you can say, "waitFor(a),"
so you don't--
you don't have to have
data dependencies.
You can just say,
"Do this after that."
And then, let's talk about
asynchronous real quick.
This is the silliest
asynchronous pipeline
you could make.
It's just a delay.
"Do something after
five seconds," right?
So all this does is,
when you run it,
it says how many seconds
to run for.
It enqueues a task,
a callback task,
which is built into
the system,
says "Count down the seconds,
call me back,"
and then, you know,
it enqueues it,
and the pipeline A--
API has built-in routing
to call you back
on your actual object.
It'll reconstruct
the object for you
and then dump you into,
kind of, the exactly--
the state you
were in before,
and then "run"
you right there.
So when you get called here,
"self" has all the different
methods you're used to
and it feels like you're in
the same pipeline again.
So--so this is also how
we execute the Mapper Framework
in the Pipeline API and so on.
And anything that's asynchronous
you can run this way.
Any toolkit you've already
built that's asynchronous,
you can run it this way.
So this is how you connect
to existing tools.
It's just like,
"I'm going to run,"
schedule some stuff to happen,
give that stuff a callback.
It's opaque--
just, you know,
enqueue a task
that looks like this,
so whatever framework
you're using
can then enqueue that task,
and when that framework's done,
the task goes in,
it calls me back,
and then the callback
function runs,
and then it can figure
out what it needs to do.
It can move to the next state,
you can do multiple callbacks
for every asynchronous worker.
It's totally up to you
what you do here,
so it's just--
this is the kind of the way to,
like, connect into other pieces.
Java has the same thing.
It's done
a little differently.
In Java,
we actually have "Promises."
So "Promises"
are like "Futures,"
but they're like "Futures"
from somebody else.
So this is a "Promise"
that somebody else
will fill this value.
So in this example,
I have an--I have something
that I want to go find out
everybody's favorite color.
Okay?
So I send them an email.
I have their address,
send them an email,
say, "Hey, here's your token,"
and then with that--
with that token
I want to then save the color
that somebody gave me.
So see the bottom
"futureCall(new SaveColor()"?
So that's--that's the--
the piece that actually
uses the--
the "Promised" value,
and then what this means
is that some other agent,
some other framework,
some web request handler--
it doesn't matter--
can call
"submitPromisedValue"
anytime in the future
using that token.
As soon as it
submits that value,
the "SaveColor" pipeline
will get kicked off.
So it's all, kind of,
event-driven
based on data dependencies.
And then, finally, I--
Sorry.
Half-- one before finally,
there's "Finalized," which is,
sometimes you've jut got to do
something when you're done.
So MapReduce, you've always
got to delete files
when you're done.
So the Pipeline API
just has that built in.
"Finalize," you know,
"Map," "Shuffle," "Reduce,"
and then delete all
the blobstore files
that were passed
into this thing.
So that's built--
that's a primary feature
of the system.
And then, finally, there's
the "Production" part,
which is basically, like,
you need to be able to
abort a pipeline
all the way to the root,
you need to be able
to retry a pipeline,
you need to be
able to set status,
you need to be able to do
it from the inside
or from the outside.
All these tools are there.
So if you've ever dealt with
workflows in "Production,"
these are the tools
I've always wanted,
and so they're all there
for you to use.
So language differences.
So coming to Java,
functional testing,
some production optimization
of the way
that the entities are
constructed, status, links,
integration with
Mapper Framework
to make full MapReduce
for App Engine Java.
Maybe we'll add "Finalized."
Python has support
for named return values.
It's a pretty
advanced feature.
You can check it out.
Probably won't add that.
Java ha--can serialize
anything, which is cool,
so Java has this edge
where you can just pass
all your classes around.
In Python, you can only
use JSON-able types.
Okay? So that's--you can't
pass raw objects though,
you have to have something
that can be serialized in JSON.
Python probably won't
add promises either,
because that's not
really the style.
So let's get back to
this data join example.
So this has
been kind of a moving target
over the last few weeks.
So I'm going to--
Well, I'll get to it
in a second, but--
So this is the big
diagram I had
at the beginning,
if you remember.
Again, we Map
the "Category," "Item,"
"Sales" on the left, so
those would be child pipelines
that would get
run doing Maps.
The outputs of all those
would then get joined
into one Shuffle,
and then the Shuffle output
would be passed to Reduce,
then the Reduce output
would get passed to a Map,
and then the Map
would get passed
to another Shuffle
and another Reduce. Okay?
So you can see, the first
part is really the join here.
You can imagine other things
being joined in
at other parts along the way.
Okay?
So this is, like,
the simplest graph I can make,
but you can think of
a lot of other, kind of,
crazy graphs with
a lot of other inputs.
But--so earlier today,
Mike Aizatskyi pushed out--
who is my colleague--
pushed out the Mapper--
MapR--full MapReduce
for App Engine
using the Mapper Framework
and Pipeline API together.
It's in the projects,
and I wanted to show you
how you'd describe this whole
workflow using his system,
and using the Pipeline API.
So the moving target thing
I was talking about is that,
wha--what the IP--
API that Mike's pushed out
has been a moving target,
so I do not have
an example for you
to run right now
that runs this code,
but I will very soon
and I'll--
I'll get it out there
so you can all run it.
But, I want to show you
what the code looks like,
just so you can understand
the kinds of things
that this is able to do.
So data--so here's
the data join
on the Pipeline API.
So the first thing
we need to do
is the left part of this.
Actually,
I have this in red.
Yeah. So this part.
So Mapping three things
together, joining them,
and then doing "Shuffle"
and a "Reduce."
That's, like,
the first step.
I want to do that part.
So here's the Python code
to describe that.
I want to run
three Map pipelines,
one for "Categories,"
one for "Items,"
and one for "Sales."
The first "MapPipeline"
is going to call
"map categories"
on everything,
reading from the Datastore
of the "Category" "entity kind."
The second one will call
"map items" on the "Items"
Datastore kind.
The third one will do
"map sales" on "Sales" kind.
Pretty easy.
And then I'll take the results
of the--all three,
append them together
and then pass them
to the "ShufflePipeline."
That will shuffle them
all together,
collate them by "item id."
So this, I think
it's 15 lines,
describes
the left side of this.
There's obviously
Mapper code in there
that's maybe one or two lines
each to actually pull out
the fields into tuples,
but the point is, like,
the hard part, in my opinion,
which is connecting the pieces,
is really simple.
That's all it is.
So once I've gotten
that result,
then I need the rest.
So--so here's
the whole sales report.
I yield that pipeline
I just told you,
so "JoinOnItemId" gives me back
a future of "joined data,"
then I run "Reduce" on that,
reducing the items,
output it to "Bloblstore"
as records,
then I run "MapReduce"
on the output again,
which inverts pairs
and then sums the values.
So that's those two functions
using the "RecordsReader"
and the "RecordsOutputWriter."
And that's it.
And then there's another
future in there
for passing in
the "reduce" output.
So this is another,
you know, 10, 15 lines
to describe
the second part,
which is the Map expansion
and the Shuffle reduction.
And so through--just--
you know,
about 25, 30 lines
of code total,
you can describe
this whole pipeline
through a series
of data dependencies
that are functionally
described--
procedurally described.
So that's--that's
where we're going.
So I'm going to have
this example for you guys.
I'm sorry
I don't have it today,
but this is what
we're going to have
as a demo of the Pipeline API
to show you how big you can go,
but I hope
I've given you an idea
of the kind of
class of problems
that we can solve
using this API.
And that's it.
So if there are any questions,
please come up to the mic.
[clapping]
Yep.
man: I think
it's fantastic...
Slatkin:
Thanks.
man:
For my applications,
and I think the syntax is
a little bit more complicated
when you compare it
to functional programming.
You know, functional
programming has this idea
of hierarchic functions
where you can return
a function as a return type
and that executes,
so that will take care of
the pipelining problem.
I know it's hard problem
for Java,
because you can't directly
return the function
but probably, it's--at least
for Python it would be easier.
Slatkin: Yeah, we--
I think we thought
of some ways to simplify,
you know, basically get rid
of a lot of the wrapper
syntax in the Pipeline API,
so you could add a--
maybe you could add, like,
an annotation
to existing function
and that would just work,
or you could return a function
that then is run.
We want to do
a lot of these things.
There's kind of
I consider that the "sugar",
so I agree that
functional languages
are shorter at describing
a lot of this stuff.
I think we'll be able
to add some things
to make it even shorter.
So I agree with you,
but, you know,
that's why functional languages
are the way they are,
is so they can do
all sorts of currying
and other events, though.
man: I think
from a use case standpoint,
it would help us a lot
in terms of, you know,
online reporting so if
you want to, you know,
create different analytics with
different sets of operatives--
Slatkin: Yep.
man: You would want to create
functions dynamically.
Slatkin: Yeah, and
that makes sense, and, you know,
one of the things we've just
talked about is maybe--you know,
Java can serialize
all kinds of really cool stuff
that Python can't,
like code,
and so I think
that we've talked about,
I mean,
under certain circumstances.
So yeah, we were trying to make
it even more dynamic to add,
you know, say, like,
first cla--"Functions"
is a first-class part
of the API,
but I don't think
we're there yet.
But, it's definitely
an interesting direction.
I--I don't know
how that'll turn out.
So. Okay, thanks.
Yep.
man: Hi.
You talked about--you were
comparing with other things
that exist inside
Google [indistinct].
Like, a very common thing
is, like,
[speaks indistinctly]
Slatkin:
Yeah.
man: So how
does that fit in?
I don't actually see,
like, if, let's say,
I read on the pipeline
and there's pieces of the code
there, of data
that I'm feeding into the
pipeline that haven't changed?
Slatkin:
Right.
man:
Does it, just--
Slatkin: So there's
no incremental builds here.
That's--I think
that's what you're asking.
man:
Yeah.
Slatkin: Yeah, there are
no incremental builds.
You'd have to build
in your own logic
into a child pipeline
to say,
"Oh, you wanted to run
MapReduce here.
I have a cache of
those input values.
Here's the last time
I ran the output values."
I think that it would be very
easy to add a cache like that
to any existing pipeline,
where it's just, like,
"Before you actually do this,
check to see
in some index,
either in a Datastore or
table or--or whatever,
if, you know,
a memorization function
or something like that.
Have I run it in
the last 15 minutes?
If I have, just return
the result I already computed.
So I think you can add
incremental builds to this,
but you'd probably
have to do it yourself.
But I think that that
might be a cool thing
we could add at the-- at
the MapReduce Framework layer,
where the framework
would understand
you could mark something
as being in incremental builds.
Say "Don't make--don't do this
more than once every hour."
And then have
that carry through.
So I think that's a direction
we want to go in, but--
man: So for example,
MapReduce does, like,
does this automatically,
like, if for most cases,
especially when it's, you know,
things are failing [indistinct].
Slatkin: You're saying,
like, partial progress,
if you restart it
and stuff like that?
man: Right.
Slatkin: Yeah.
I think
the MapReduce Framework
will do that too
to a point, but what I--
what I think's interesting
is more of running MapReduce,
like, multiple times
over the same day
over new data
or variations of the data.
man:
Mmm-hmm.
Slatkin:
And that's where we're--
I don't think
the MapReduce Frameworks--
I mean, the MapReduce Frameworks
I've worked with
don't do that part.
Like, MapReduce itself--
doesn't do that part.
So you kind of have to
add the incremental piece to it.
So I think, yeah--
that's--I mean,
I think it'd be
a cool feature to add. So.
Yeah.
man: I know that you said
you could get a StackTrace
if you get an error,
but can you also trap
the exception itself
for production code?
Slatkin:
Right.
So if you get an error--
So you're saying, like,
a concurrency error?
Like, I accidentally added
access to this value or--
man: Yeah. Well, let's say
that you have a pipeline
that goes off and fails
for some reason and--
Slatkin: Oh, oh, okay.
Yeah.
No, in--in production,
you can't catch it.
So in--so it can run
serially, so you have,
like, child pipeline--
you have parent pipeline,
child pipeline,
child pipeline.
If this thing
raises an exception,
you don't get the exception
back in the parent.
I think that'd be a
really cool thing to add.
Functionally, or, like,
or technically,
that's difficult to
implement
for a lot of reasons, but,
so far what happens is
that if the child dies
for an exception,
it'll retry
if you ask it to,
and if it retries
too many times,
it'll abort
all the way to the root,
and then it'll send
this "abort" message
to everybody saying,
"Alright,
something totally broke.
Everybody stop
what you're going to do,"
and then it emails the
administrator with the status
and the link to the page.
But adding exceptional states
would be cool.
It's something we should do.
Thanks.
Okay.
Alright, well,
thanks a lot for coming.
I know this is the last talk
of the last day,
so I appreciate you coming.
I hope I have not
hurt you too much,
and thanks again.
[clapping]